this guy's sickening no you don't get to
gaslight me and tell me i hate my own
gender everybody is so soft you like
balls oh yeah
you're locked
dude i have more balls than you'll ever
have boss i think like 20 years ago i
went on a date with tommy and i slipped
out the back door
real quick let's pick the winner of last
week's hundred dollar giveaway mom
scroll through i can barely see pick a
[ __ ] no i'm saying
just pick somebody scroll
come on
give me a sec
let's go with david guerrero
great video thanks david lit lit do you
have me for the prize um so i'm also
giving away another hundred dollars to
someone who joins the discord in my
caption get [ __ ] done university gonna
be the biggest thing around and dms me
proof on my instagram
so today we're gonna be reacting to tate
top g you know the guy
apparently you're in love with him
according to the comment section
according to the internet yes um so
we're going to be reacting to him
arguing with the super pink haired
liberal dude acting like tommy pro
oldest professional fortnite player okay
tell me more about tommy though anything
else on his back
used to be like a rock star i think he
um he had like a bunch of stuff with uh
drugs and alcohol i think don't take my
word totally for that and then he became
sober and started streaming for tonight
i actually used to watch him back when i
stopped oh i still played later [ __ ]
nuts
it's pretty funny seeing him talking to
the top g now got my mega planet already
a mega pint dude i have nothing personal
against you andrew but like
though show me your philosophy i don't
think you're a [ __ ] i think you're a
water boy
water boy for patriarchy and
capitalism and whatnot right
just let him keep going let's just let
this vomit come out
sort of regressive ideas about manhood
and uh which is why the teenage audience
like consumes it so much you know you
got these young boys that are like
grappling with feelings of powerlessness
and you come in and offer them like the
ultimate machismo idea what do you want
to be a man but you're just
i don't know
what is this we really got the giant the
johnny depp mega pint of wine right here
this is insane oh my
what do you
put
you could fit a whole bottle in here yes
that is the point of it said that on the
box i said it on the box so
you think that i am inspiring the youth
of today
the masculine youth of today to become
men and you think that's a negative
thing why why no i don't i don't think
you're inspiring them to become men
because like real men are in touch with
their emotions
and their vulnerability and don't need
to be like wielding and taking power
real men are self-aware
and and you come in offering them like
someone's face
i can't stop looking at the mannequin
too it's so funny
like the savior the guy the badass
if you're a man who's in touch with his
strength and his masculine power why
does that mean you're not
capable of reflecting in words and being
self-aware that they're not mutually
exclusive
well well apparently for you they are
though because on the one hand as you
talk about on the one hand you talk
about how you made your first million
while exploiting women on webcams is
running a webcam business exploiting
women if you kidnap them and drug them
and put them on camera then it is if
they said
sign me up i want to make some money no
yeah that's they they signed women can
make their own decisions
period you and your brother are going to
bring purity back to women so yeah you
absolutely lack self-awareness because
you yourself admit you made your your
initial money on sort of like
the
you profited off the support he's
wearing a t-shirt with a woman on it
that's not exploiting
or is it celebrating maybe tate was just
celebrating women and paying them for it
i mean what the hell is the difference
truly i don't know did have you seen the
club like have you seen the clips
of the question have you seen the clips
of the dude wearing the the mexican
outfit like the sombrero and all that
[ __ ] and he goes to a college campus and
he asks them he's like does this offend
you all these white people and they're
like yeah that's not your culture that's
very offensive and then he goes to like
mexican alley i don't know where where
it is and he's talking to all like the
old dudes and they're like yes my friend
yeah i love your outfit it doesn't
offend me
do you like my outfit oh yeah it's
awesome does my outfit offend you no not
at all i don't know i don't know why
people get so offended over [ __ ] totally
it's not even their place to get
offended they call it cultural
appropriation and i always just thought
of it as cultural celebration i i don't
think there's anything wrong with
celebrating i think it's definitely gone
a lot better but if
it was pretty bad for like because no
one's taking it anymore everyone's
speaking up and speaking their mind not
everyone and still a lot of people who
are afraid to get cancelled
there's a lot of people who are done
can't get canceled if you don't give a
[ __ ] that's right first thing the word
exploiting is an incorrect use of
language because i've never exploited
anyone in my life
well let me ask you this when you made
your first million with the women in the
webcams how many of the women who are on
those webcams earning for you how many
of them are millionaires now
the ones who made millions are also
millionaires it was fifty percent
it was
would argue the point here sir i would
argue the point here that when a girl
a girl worked for me it was 50 50. if
you work for nearly any other business
in the world you do not get 50 of the
takings if you go work on mcdonald's and
you ring up a register for an hour you
do not get 50 of that register so that
is a lie most companies pay you less
than one percent so to sit here and say
that i was killing people is absolute
fallacy so that's the first
it's like first fallacy i'll let you
talk now it's my turn that's
yeah he's not wrong
he's 100 right tate's the brain he even
said so when he was doing the webcam
industry he said the girls like didn't
know how to actually talk to the guys
because you were typing through a
keyboard so if it was an older guy the
woman would be like yeah look at this
young guy he was attractive and tate
would be like no you're freaking brad
you got to be like i'm sick of these
young guys trying to flex at all i want
a nice older guy to settle with so then
tate would get behind the keyboard and
like 20 extra earnings so it makes sense
if you wanted to work with him yeah
because then you end up making more
money even taking that smaller cut this
is just how basic business works any
business any business right you would
you like
would you like fries with that people
work for nine dollars an hour and then
those same people go and spend 40 000 a
year at college and you're trying to
tell me that that's okay that's not a
scam that's not exporting people that's
[ __ ] that's the first balance second
fallacy is this whole patriarchy
[ __ ] you're saying are outdated
ideas of masculinity yeah the idea of
patriarchy is not an outdated idea of
masculinity perhaps in the west in a
declining empire as we've already
discussed on this stream and an empire
which is an absolute decline you can
have men who sit here there's absolutely
nothing necessary about masculinity in
the modern world and that you don't need
to be strong or brave or any of these
things you can sit around and cry and
you're still a man that is not true in
most places on the planet in most places
on the planet men need to be capable and
competent because if they don't they do
not survive and i'll tell you something
now sir i'll tell you something else now
you will sit here and talk ab talk right
now about the patriarchy and how you can
be in touch with your feelings and all
this [ __ ] the second you're
physically assaulted or physically
threatened the first thing you do is you
call a toxicly masculine police officer
to turn up your weapon to protect you
because you cannot protect yourself it's
actually insane how articulate andrew
tate is how he can just go on a tangent
for so long no why do these things even
need to be said this is just obvious
logic yeah this is stupid yeah this
guy's not calling somebody that looks
like him to come save him he's not not
against the idea of masculine power
you're not against the idea of men who
have masculine imperatives to defense
all you've done is outsource it to
someone else to do at the end of a phone
call because you're too scared to do it
yourself so you're [ __ ] lying you're
alive
you don't want to do them yourself and
you hope everyone else does them for you
so you can sit around and play [ __ ]
video games
my the point i posit is there's more
than just physicality with men and you
talk about exploitation you absolutely
exploit people with your affiliate links
that is exploitation this [ __ ] again oh
my god you give people an opportunity to
take a piece of the pie that's not
exploiting anybody i i don't know since
when affiliate marketing is expo is
exploiting people nobody has and nobody
is forced to be an affiliate it's one of
the most gene exactly if you are just
people make entire livings just being
affiliates for bunches of different
businesses that's how most content
creators make their livings as being
affiliates like i as well as bucky and
clicks no anybody who's an instance or
knows that affiliate links are total
[ __ ] because basically you give an
affiliate link to somebody who promotes
you
and he makes a little money off of it
but you're getting free advertising
that's exploitation it's not free you're
paying the guy for it you just said it
it's not free this is the problem logic
has gone out the [ __ ] window totally
out the window yeah when i launched the
get [ __ ] done university i'm having an
affiliate program attached and i'm going
to take over tick tock with it it's not
[ __ ] scamming or exploiting people
it's just a good marketing strategy but
it's not even that you're actually
offering something of real value that
can help people in their lives yeah they
relate to it and they use it and it's
like the only way to make money is by
getting other people to sign up i'm
teaching dozens of different ways to
make money maybe we should get this guy
to uh you know talk do a chapter on uh
how to make money on fortnight that's
not exploitation at all having lit he's
this guy's taking money from teenagers
on fortnight from kids on fortnight and
he's talking about exploitation when you
give someone a business opportunity with
an affiliate link am i missing that i
like am i correct about that no it's
little kids on fortnite that are like oh
here it takes ten dollars i like
watching you play oh my god this guy's
sickening and i'm sure in person he's
nice if he was at the kitchen table we'd
have a nice he's just he's just a little
bit of a [ __ ] it's a debate he's not a
bad guy he's just a puss he's got a
permanent [ __ ] hat on yeah look at his
hair i'll go to the salon and be like
i'll take the [ __ ] hat i'll take the
i'll take the acting like tommy and talk
about like purely physical strength like
first off if i get assaulted i'm
probably not gonna call the police okay
because the police aren't actually very
adept at actually solving crimes right
they don't they don't function very well
in the absolute the actual solution of
crimes they show up later and just sort
of muck up the business correct
i agree with that so how would you
defend yourself in the effect of an
assault you'll just lay there and take
it
well so it would it would depend on the
assault i would probably remove myself
from the situation right that's not
obviously that's not something that's
gonna be applicable to the scenario
we're doing here from the stream we're
not gonna pretend you can run away
because that just defeats the point well
what are we are we here to talk about
some hypothetical assault oh no we're no
we're not here
99 of americans never even encounter a
violent crime
is that true i wonder if that's true
because 99
what i've seen a lot of [ __ ] yeah so
yeah
maybe it's because we live in the city i
don't know i am curious about his
you're from brooklyn because you know
maybe it's
a little wild out in the streets i'm
sitting here saying you live in a very
soft society you're completely correct
you live in assault
if you were the same person in most
places on the planet you would have had
your ass beat because you are weak and
weaklings are not restricted let me tell
you something my friend my friend i'll
let you talk afterwards never in human
history in any single civilization in
any single empire across the history of
earth have men been celebrated for their
weakness ever once it doesn't matter if
you were an aztec or the or the mao
dynasty from china all the way to south
america every single history book you
can read men who were respected and men
who had stories written about them were
written about them because they were
strong weak men have never been
respected weak men have never mattered
for you to come along and say i think
it's okay to be weak is fine that is
your initiative that is your decision
the reason
dude i have more balls than you'll ever
have boss i just i've got more balls
than you've ever had boss
i've got more balls than pink hair has
that's the truth are you kidding you're
changing the goal post here because
you're the one who's sitting here
calling emotional strength and emotional
vulnerability you're defining it as
weakness well he didn't he didn't say
that he just said they're not mutually
exclusive you can be strong you can be
alpha you can kick ass and you can also
be self-aware and kill things if we were
to stand side by side in front of 100
women in front of 100 [ __ ] police
officers 100 [ __ ] enemies who want to
kill us whatever it is they would all
choose to [ __ ] with you before they
choose to [ __ ] with me because they look
at me and i have a certain status and a
certain presence which comes from my
physical strengths
but because of the things i've gone
through to become this physical specimen
of man they know i'm not the kind of guy
who you really want to mess with they
look at you and go he is a victim
because that's what you look like my
friend and it's your own choice
i love kate's mentality of how you have
to like go through a lot of struggle as
a man to become a truly high value man
so i remember senior year when life was
like going too good i was like damn i
wish a girl i should just like get a
girlfriend and then have her break my
heart so i have more like motivation and
i can like become a gym like a crazy gym
rat or just like have insane motivation
for my business and then my friend
screwed me over and then i was funny you
got what you wanted but it came in a
different way yeah it is funny how you
always end up getting what you want it's
just never exactly how you want it yeah
no like right away though when it
happened i didn't even dwell on it for
more than like an hour after we talked
about it i just like started working
like that night see that's just it
though the only reason they would choose
you in that element is because of the
patriarchal [ __ ] male dominating
society stop again patriarch he is a
victim everyone who's like the
patriarchy holds me down the patriarchy
holds me down is held down because they
allow it because they are victims and
they just sit and complain and it's
everybody else's fault that they haven't
succeeded frankly the patriarchy has
been pretty good to me there are times
when they've been shitty to me and i
just keep going i just keep swimming
just keep swimming i'm not gonna sit and
dwell if i get mad at something i get
mad i go let it out somewhere and then i
come back and carry on and these people
just sit and dwell and complain and
complain and complain it's [ __ ]
torture i just don't ever like
complaining about things that are out of
my control but you were raised that way
right we're not allowed to sit and piss
and moan about things and complain in
this house bitching about the government
and all that stuff like probably like
they actually give a [ __ ] about you bro
just move on with your life and do your
own thing stop worrying about them or if
you really care do something about it
besides vote get involved go in the deep
end
i would say tate wishes they weren't
aware i wish they were in a ring too
he's gonna be a ball in the corner
name a society from history that was not
patriarchal see that listen to me
in africa at one point there was a
society where nobody knows about it and
it was obviously overrun by men the
reason you cannot name a single society
in history that was not a patriarchy is
because all of the societies and i'm
sure there were some which were not
patriarchal were destroyed by
patriarchal societies they were wiped
out to face the planet because they are
not competitive
they do not have monuments to find and
the point i'm making is that in the
harsh reality of ultra competitiveness
only patriarchal societies can survive
so the reason you cannot name one from
history is because all the ones that
tried this idea that you're trying to
purport were destroyed in real time it's
true as the us is shifting more away
from patriarchal society it's becoming
weaker testosterone levels are down
across the board men are just becoming
more [ __ ]
really in the cities you go to middle
america and as testosterone in the
coffee it's fine and i think it's just
because we grew up in i i've lived in
the city my whole life so maybe it's
just all the stuff yeah maybe and all
the stuff we see on the news it just
talks about the fringes so you got the
fringe right lunatics and you got the
fringe left lunatics like this guy who's
saying that everybody's out to get them
and
it's not really the case though really
think about the five men and young men
in your world that we deal with on a
daily basis your dad your friends their
dads none of them are [ __ ] mary's not
one no because i don't surround myself
with this mary so it's not so to go back
to our anecdotal evidence and our
experience we we don't see a lot of that
yeah so
don't let don't let this guy pink tommy
say that the society is changing because
the news will tell you that it is to
keep you angry but in reality it's not
we had a few years of nonsense you're
saying it's more of just like the media
and all that [ __ ] rather than the
media giving them a megaphone yeah yeah
i mean people feed from their phones
it's like 12 hours a day staring into a
device that other people are feeding
them information through and they're
only feeding into things that they think
they agree with because
you know what's even crazier is that
your phone like optimizes to what you
want to see so if you're like a liberal
it'll show you like more like on tick
tock it'll show you more liberal stuff
and like liberals owning conservatives
and the same thing if you're
conservative it'll show like it's pretty
insane how the algorithm learns to cater
to what you want to see to keep you on
the app longer which just feeds into
these crazier beliefs and to get you
more and more upset and then you just go
more and more alt to the to the right or
all to the left and then it's those
pillars that are so
they're both [ __ ] checking out's the
only way yeah you just gotta do that
this is all [ __ ] i remember back
there in like the the end of court end
of kovid and during the election and i
was posting all like the trump [ __ ] and
i was like these [ __ ] that's not what
happened you know i was arguing with
[ __ ] on social media and then now i
look at it and i'm like it's all a
[ __ ] scam what am i even what am i
arguing with these bumbler clubs for no
i know i used to do it too not anymore
it's just a waste of time
right as we stand right now in america
which i wouldn't even call it a
patriarchal society because it isn't
because females have more rights under
the law than women than men oh my god
bro
he said that women are more favored
about in the law than than men they have
more rights yeah absolutely no question
about it no [ __ ] oh wait let's see what
let's see what pink tommy's got to say
all that's going to happen is that other
countries like russia like china like
countries which are still patriarchal
will remain more competitive than the
west and you're not going to fix the
world america's just going up a third
world [ __ ] so throw it in this
[ __ ] patriarchy
fix a [ __ ] thing you live in a clown
clown dude
yeah no no i don't i mean i do live in a
clown because there are people like you
that are sitting there like pushing this
inane philosophy so yeah i get it i
accept that but first off we haven't
seen a non-patriarchal society yet okay
sorry i have to do politics did you see
carmel hours yesterday in the news or
this week or whatever it was and she's
like hi my name is kamala harris and my
pronouns are she and her and
i am wearing a blue suit i am kamala
harris my pronouns are she and her i'm a
woman sitting at the table wearing a
blue suit she was running a meeting as
the vice president of our country oh
it's there i am wearing a blue suit so
this is a representation of what female
leadership looks like
because they were great female leaders
but this guy is saying we're moving
towards it so if he thinks that that's
leadership god help him let's have the
civil war and get it over with and you
can go live in that land and i'm gonna
live in tate's land the funniest is when
it was trump and hillary in the election
and ever all the people that wanted
hillary only wanted her because she's a
woman they didn't even know why they
wanted it
the clintons are some of the most
corrupt people in the country you
mentioned the roman empire the roman
empire didn't fall because of laziness
it fell because of overconfidence
because of an income gap between the
richest and the poor and because of
political corruption all three things
that are sort of happening in america
right now so absolutely america could
fall but it's not because men were
turning soft right that's the idea of
men being they're soft
because the idea of men being soft
andrew is a battle cry of men who see
that purely physical stature is no
longer the only defining quality men
still need to be strong and nowadays
women need to be strong but feminizing
men is not the answer let women be the
best feminine women they can be smart
they can do everything and let men be
masculine let them all be the best at
what they're natural at and what they
can be taught and not only are people
becoming less masculine men are also
becoming just lazier it's kind of sad
how how many friends and people i know
that just don't do anything with their
lives they just sit around and waste
time that's generational that's females
too it's insane [ __ ] society's just
going down the kakaju you know could
line me and you up and all those brutes
like the cops or somebody looking for
pure strength would choose you to defend
them but anybody who was like who was
from a marginalized group that was
looking for an emotional defender those
people would pick me would you rather be
an emotional defender deal with your
[ __ ] i'm sorry grow up everybody is so
soft and i'm not saying we should go
around hurting people's feelings but
everyone's got to get a backbone i mean
this is enough and they wouldn't pick
some musculars
because because they know that oh pretty
girl's back she's watching this
my instagram's right here baby if she's
watching come talk to me first and i'll
let you know if you can talk to my son
we go to your instagram page and you
talk about being the messiah and all
this other bs you want people to follow
you like you're some sort of like deity
boss and that's actually a sign of your
own weakness at work right that's coming
from your own trauma i think like 20
years ago i went on a date with tommy
and i slipped out the back door
fact the secondly the fact that i'm
actually mixed race that i grew up in
the south side of chicago with my father
absolutely well i more know more about
marginalized communities than you do
because you are as white as they [ __ ]
come and you're sitting there talking
about
your marginalization absolutely yes
i never woke up i'm brown so i had to
find this white guy with pink hair to
fight for me i woke up
and that's the point you fight for
yourself you fight for yourself when
you're a man that requires all forms of
power whether it be emotional mental and
physical you to sit here telling men
they should be as weak as possible
sitting around doing [ __ ] nothing
it's not good for society as a whole i
mean maybe tommy was bullied when he was
little and he's just pissed at the
patriarchy since i don't
know what drives i didn't even really
know where i'm kind of confused about
masculinity like what is like i'd like
to get beneath this and see what's
tommy's problem we should call him i
think all men if you're a good man
you're gonna have a traumatic life
that's a part of being a man and i think
that i think it's not even a part of
being a man it's a part of being a human
being on the planet you're gonna have a
traumatic life
right but you gotta heal the trauma the
trauma doesn't make you unless you heal
it if
all you do
is
sit in the trauma and talk about healing
the trauma and scream about it you're
not exactly
you're not gonna heal it you're just
throwing gasoline on the fire everything
you do in life is about life is all
about energy if you're constantly
talking and dwelling on negative [ __ ]
then more negative stuff is going to
come around you like you heal from the
trauma but like your healing is like
it's like when you're working out you're
ripping your muscle fibers and then
they'll be coming back stronger that's
what tate's saying that when you're
going through trauma it's like you're
ripping yourself a little bit and then
coming back even stronger like he's
saying you're healing it's not like he's
saying to just like stuff it down be a
man i don't care now this guy what what
i see and i'm making a generalization is
that in the type of people that he's
hanging with the word trauma is down to
the tiniest little transgression so it
was like the me too movement like oh
somebody brushed his hand against my ass
on the subway like yeah that was shitty
and he deserves to you know take a
kick to the shin for that at least but
that's not trauma that's just a gross
experience and they'll take that and
they'll they'll turn it into
my story i got cat called
and yeah cat called like come on same
[ __ ] like
they've been cat called it's not trauma
you gotta toughen up because it
diminishes real trauma these people make
trauma at everything my flight was late
i'm traumatizing any man who's any man
who's not had difficulty any man who's
not gone through something that's
difficult is not very good at being a
man because when [ __ ] hits the fan
people turn to the nearest man in the
room and say what is the solution
someone just broke in the house you go
to the man [ __ ] there's a natural
disaster a hurricane you go to the man
there's a war you go to the men
who have not been through trauma i'm not
very good at being men because they're
not dealing with obama wait so pause
right there
because you said when you go to war you
go to the men but the only reason you
have a war is because of men and their
lack of awareness about their own
feelings
that is not the reason for war there are
a lot of reasons for war that is not the
reason we go to war okay so more women
leaders we wouldn't even have more men
literally are responsible for war by a
lack of emotional awareness and that's
how it starts interesting so let's let's
make let's make this the final point
before we move on you just said if all
the leaders were women who wouldn't even
have war i just i said if we had more
women leaders yes there would be less
war to prove
tate's point about trauma there was
something that i was taught growing up
so grandpa sarafino who is my father in
his teens so say late 50s he was really
becoming a punk and he was just being an
[ __ ] and he was fighting with
teachers at school and he was a greaser
and he was all this he was in school
got in a fight with the hall monitor
went to the principal's office the
principal started giving him a hard time
and he picked up his books and threw
them all at the principal and the
principal threw him out this was a few
weeks before graduation he got kicked
out of school got expelled he never
graduated high school but he went home
that day and he sat in the living room
and he lit a cigarette in the living
room he's 17. my grandfather his father
walked in and said how are you doing he
was i'm 17. i'm going to do whatever the
hell i want and the way my father told
it is his father kicked the living [ __ ]
out of him beat him off of every wall in
that living room kicked his ass left him
in a ball and said you know
this is my house but you're gonna be a
man and this but this is my house and
you're not talking to me or your mother
or anybody like that the lesson that my
father passed on to us everybody needs
one good beating
and that's a metaphor whether it's a
real beating like what he got because he
said it taught him he straightened up
after that that's how bad the beating
was though and ended up being just a
wonderful man a family man a strong man
but also a kind man but if he didn't get
that beat and who knows what path he
might have been on so tate's right you
gotta have some [ __ ] go down to become
strong and this guy tommy is saying when
you have [ __ ] go down you got to solve
your feelings you're good you're going
to own your feelings
and you've got to be there in your
feelings could you imagine like laying
it like laying in bed next to tommy at
night and be like
my god is he crying again you don't get
to gaslight me and tell me i hate my own
gender just because i'm displaying a a a
version of manhood that you're
uncomfortable looking at i don't know
you don't get you don't get to say i
because i present a version of manhood
that has struggled just like you that
has conquered just like you but it is
out lives outside the idealized
patriarchy that was sold to me you don't
get to gaslight me because you're
uncomfortable
the reason you're totally wrong saying
that the world would have less war if
there was no female leaders is because
if you actually ask anybody who's been
the corporate world for long enough the
companies that have the most arguments
the most difficult corporate structures
to deal with in fact even if you ask
most women they say i don't like having
a woman boss
true what like you'd rather have a man
boss yeah i've had two awesome female
bosses and um
i can't say enough about them but they
were chill but they were they acted the
same way as the best male bosses all
other female bosses i would have loved
to just like throw them down a flight of
stairs they were terrible terrible to
work for emotional mean competitive if
you did well they
knock you down a few pegs just to teach
you a lesson where man if you if you did
well he would um he'd be like all right
great you can handle more go go run with
this ball run with that ball and nancy
and krista were the two female bosses i
had that man i would have found those
women to the ends of the earth they were
awesome whole bunch of women in charge
nothing about [ __ ] [ __ ] fest and
it's [ __ ] show every single [ __ ]
person who's ever worked in corporate
knows that every single person who's
ever worked in the world knows that that
women actually as beautiful as they are
and they're good lots of different
things they would perhaps not perhaps
they would prefer to work for a male
boss because it's a stronger more clear
leadership structure having a bunch of
women in charge of countries is not
going to make a [ __ ] this guy again
yeah oh my god and the fact that you
believe that showed your entire mental
models
like to actually put hole in the chat
and let's see who
you know i don't even like automatically
agree with tate i try to like really
critically think about what i see and
why i think it good you should be doing
that with everything i don't
automatically agree with tate i've
thought this stuff through in the past
and i yeah i just haven't thought i
think of the patriarchy being called so
bad maybe the patriarchy only likes
certain kinds of people and
when you show up with pink hair and
wearing a britney spears t-shirt
maybe they're looking at you like for
god's sake
thank you for coming on um yeah thank
you so much i actually think tommy's not
a bad person i think if we could just
talk about other stuff like music and
movies
that we might like tommy love you you
know this is just too much for us with
him dude i did i did andy take care of
brother hassan i just say steve boss i
appreciate you man putting the word out
there thank you guys uh he's i don't
know him personally i have nothing
against him personally his he lives in
he's a new age thinker he lives in the
new think the idea that the way the
world runs and has always run is a bad
thing and that if we change everything
from the ground up it's somehow going to
become a magically better place
obviously he has no proof or any
references for his way of like his way
of thinking because it's never been
tested before it's an untested theory i
think that him for him to come along and
say such blanket statements said if we
changed all the world leaders to women
there wouldn't be war is inane and
asinine i think for him to say that a
man who's physically strong can't be
mentally strong is also stupid but i
also understand why he's saying the
ideas he's saying because he has a
natural insecurity based on the fact
that he's not a physical specimen of man
and the way he gets around it is to
pretend that that's not important so
time will prove me right but i'm not
just picking his nose you know what
go back
look at it are there going to be a safer
societies overall so no there's no way
this is that's a joke right dude i don't
know
click stop
i'm trying to defend you here bro with
the fortnite shirt and [ __ ] picking
it i've got eight minutes left on that
let's get your rating on tommy one to
ten i think tommy look seems like a
really nice person i don't like his take
on masculinity and femininity and
victimhood but i think he's a he think
he's a nice person so i'm i i don't i
don't feel comfortable writing him at
all gotta give him a reading no i'm
trying to do anything question mark out
of 10. i think i [ __ ] on tommy enough
today i mean just a dog playing [ __ ] is
he doing
uh 99 of you guys who are watching are
not subscribed so please hit the bell
i'm giving 100 to someone who likes
subscribes and then joins the discord in
my comments get [ __ ] done university
no you're not eligible
all right
and i are
[Music]
on the [ __ ] won't last long